104
in the uk today the hottest ever it's
unbelievable they're just not equipped
for a lot of those homes don't have air
conditioning or any of that kind of
stuff can you imagine 104 with no ac
and and again yeah they're just not
they're well don't deal with those kind
of course we're
the desert right but there they've never
seen that temperature so that's why you
have fatalities you have those issues
there so of course
uh that's a big issue there uh changing
gears here thought we'd lighten the mood
a little bit because we had our i love
it when our viewers interact with us and
the minute we talked about the uh the
trapper keeper i had to share this with
you we were talking about school
supplies yes school supplies earlier
this was sent to us by one of our
viewers rosalie lynn
who sent us a picture of the trapper
keepers you remember those oh there it
is our
right this is since we're getting back
to school right so we love it again when
you guys interact with us when you send
us pictures or you you post that picture
there from rosie leland what's this one
what's up we got you a trap where does
this one come from tracy wilson our
executive producer has one you can keep
all your weather data in there ted
seriously i'm going to need that for
sure right 109 degrees our official high
for the day today i want to compare that
to the sweltering temperatures across
the nation because we've got a big heat
wave going across the u.s 109 in
oklahoma city today they give an
excessive heat warning there because
they don't typically see these numbers
that we're getting here 102 and someone
right now these are current temperatures
and new neighborhoods here to show you
109 for downtown 109 for green valley
107 for southern highlands 107 for
henderson denise bryant can you sign my
trapper keeper after the show it's like
the old school days 119 in death valley
105 for prop 94 up in rachel here's your
feels-like temperatures around the
nation and when you see oranges and
yellows across the lower 48 states you
know it's hot across the u.s right now
even 82 in the
twin cities 103 right now feels like
temperature in oklahoma city 89 to 87 in
the delmarva in new york city right now
that again that is with humidity that's
your heat indices when you feel that
humidity on your skin all right here's a
look at your weather alerts too in fact
we have heat
heat advisories for the lower plane
states all the way down to texas this
extends over to memphis and look at that
all the way to upstate new york too back
here at home as far as the monsoon
storms go the radar showing a few
leftover storms off into arizona
specifically mohave county while things
are winding down here and also lincoln
county we're starting going to see the
air dry out even more as the monsoon
retreats as that high sits on top of us
once that high gets on top of us our
temperatures are really going to soar in
fact here's the next three days 1 10 11
and that goes for thursday and friday
too are we going to reach records we'll
hear your records we'll come close but
we don't think we'll reach them but
we'll see if that changes with later
updates to the weather forecast evening
planet shows 108 by 7 pm even 9 o'clock
we're still talking 104 even with the
sun going down the
11 o'clock temperature at 8 news now 11
when we go on 11 tonight don't forget to
join us we'll still be right at the
century mark in fact at 8 a.m we'll be
at 95 degrees you know tomorrow it's
going to be a hot day for sure we're
going to top out the day tomorrow 110
after that like we said the numbers are
going to stay hot these next few days
excessive heat watches been issued for
thursdays for some parts of the region
they go through friday the weekend we'll
drop the numbers just a little more and
next week we're hoping so it looks like
chances of the monsoon could be
returning as early as monday